Let's go ahead and get started.
OK, so today we have one topic
to finish up very briefly
from last time.
So if you remember, when
we finished off last time,
we were talking about the
example of a multithreaded Web
server.
So the example that
we were talking about,
and this is an
example that I'm going
to use throughout the lecture
today consisted of a Web server
with, this example
consists of a Web server
with three main modules
or main components.
So it consists, the three
modules are a networking
module, a Web server module --
-- which is in charge of
generating, for example,
HTML pages, and then a disk
module which is in charge
of reading data off a disk.
OK, so this thing is
going to be communicating
with the disk, which I've
drawn as a cylinder here.
So what happens is
that client requests
come in to this Web server.
They come in to
the network module.
The network module
forwards those requests
on to the Web server.
The Web server is in
charge of generating,
say, the HTML page that
corresponds to the request.
And in order to do that, it
may need to read some data off
of the disk.
So it forwards this request
onto the disk module, which
goes and actually gets
the page from the disk
and at some point later,
the disk returns the page
to the Web server.
The Web server returns the
page to the network module,
and then the network module
sends the answer back
over the network to the user.
So this is a very simple
example of a Web server.
It should be sort
of familiar to you
since you have just spent a
while studying the Flash Web
server.
So you can see that this is
sort of a simplified description
of what a Web server does.
So if you think about
how you actually
go about designing a Web
server like this, of course
it's not the case that there
is only one request that
is moving between these modules
at any one point in time.
So, in fact, there may be
multiple client requests that
come in to the network module.
And the network module
may want to have
multiple outstanding pages
that it's asking the Web
server to generate.
And the Web server itself might
be requesting multiple items
from the disk.
And so, in turn, that means
that at any point in time
there could be sort
of multiple results.
There could be results streaming
back in from the disk which
are going into the
Web server, which
is sort of chewing on
results and producing pages
to the network module.
And so it's possible
for there to be
sort of queues that are building
up between these modules
both on the send and receive.
So, I'm going to
draw a queue, I'll
draw a queue just sort as a
box with these vertical arrows
through it.
So there is some
buffering that's
happening between the
sort of incoming requests
and the outgoing requests
on these modules.
OK, and this buffering
is a good thing.
And we're going to
talk more about this
throughout the lecture today
because what it allows us to do
is it allows us to
decouple the operations
of these different modules.
So, for example, the disk module
can be reading a page from disk
while the HTML page, while the
HTML server is, for example
simultaneously generating
an HTML page that
wants to return to the client.
But in this
architecture, you can
see that, for example,
when the Web server wants
to produce a result, it can
only produce a result when
the disk pages that it needs
are actually available.
So the Web server is dependent
on some result from the disk
module being available.
So if we were to look
at just this Web server,
I'm going to call this the
HTML thread here and the disk
thread, so these
two threads that
are on the right side of this
diagram that I've drawn here,
If you were to look
at the code that
was running in these things,
and we saw this last time,
the code might look
something like this.
So the HTML thread is just going
to sit in a loop continually
trying to de-queue information
from this queue that is shared
between it and the disk thread.
And then, the disk thread
is going to be in a loop
where it continually
reads blocks off the disk,
and then enqueues
them onto this queue.
So this design at first
seems like it might be fine.
But then if you start thinking
about what's really going on
here, there could be a problem.
So, suppose for example that
the queue is of a finite length.
It only has a certain
number of elements in it.
Now when we keep calling enqueue
over and over and over again,
it's possible that if the
HTML thread isn't consuming
these pages off the queue fast
enough, that the queue could
fill up, and it could
overflow, right?
So that might be
a problem that we
want to sort of make a condition
that we would explicitly
check for in the code.
And so we could
do that by adding
a set of conditions like this.
So what you see here is that
I have just augmented the code
with these two additional
variables, used and free, where
used indicates the number blocks
that are in the queue that
are currently in use.
And free indicates
the number of blocks
that are in the code,
that are in the queue
that are currently free.
So what this loop does
is that the disk thread
says it only wants to enqueue
something onto the queue
when there are some free blocks.
So, it has a while loop
that just loops forever
and ever and ever while
they're waiting when
there are no free blocks, OK?
And similarly, the
HTML thread is just
going to wait forever when
there are no used blocks, OK?
And then, when the disk
thread enqueues a block
onto the queue, it's going
to decrement the free count
because it's reduced
the number of things
that are in the queue.
And it's going to increment the
used count because now there
is one additional thing that's
available in the queue, OK?
So this is a simple
way in which now we've
made it so these things
are waiting for each other.
They are coordinating
with each other
by use of these two shared
variables used in free.
OK, so these two threads
share these variables.
So that's fine.
But if you think about this
from a scheduling point of view,
there still is a little bit of
a problem with this approach.
So in particular, what's
going on here is that, oops,
when one of these threads enters
into one of these while loops,
it's just going to
sit there checking
this condition over and over
and over and over again, right?
So then the thread scheduler
schedules that thread.
It's going to repeatedly
check this condition.
And that's maybe
not so desirable.
So suppose, for example,
that the HTML thread
enters into this loop and
starts looping because there's
no data available.
Now, what really we
would like to have happen
is for the disk thread to be
allowed to get a chance to run,
so maybe it can produce some
data so that the HTML thread
can then go ahead and operate.
But, with this while loop
there, we can't quite do that.
We just sort of waste
the CPU during the time
we are in this while loop.
So, instead what
we are going to do
is introduce the set of what
we call sequence coordination
operators.
So in order to
introduce this, we're
going to add something,
a new kind of data type
that we call an eventcount.
An eventcount, you
can just think of it
as an integer that indicates
the number of times
that something has occurred.
It's just some sort of
running counter variable.
And we're going to
introduce two new routines.
So these two routines are
called wait and notify.
OK, so wait takes two arguments.
It takes one of these
eventcount variables.
And it takes a value.
OK, so what wait says
is check the value
of this eventcount thing, and
see whether when we check it,
the value of this eventcount
is less than or equal to value.
If eventcount is less than or
equal to value, then it waits.
And what it means
for it to wait is
that it tells the
thread scheduler
that it no longer wants to be
scheduled until somebody later
calls this notify routine on
this same eventcount variable.
OK, so wait says wait, if
this condition is true,
and then notify says,
wake up everybody
who's waiting on this variable.
So we can use these routines in
the following way in this code.
And it's really very
straightforward.
We simply change our iteration
through our while loops
into wait statements.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to have the HTML thread
wait until the value of used
becomes greater than zero.
And we're going to have
our disk thread wait
until the value of free
becomes greater than zero.
And then the only other thing
that we have to add to this
is simply a call to notify.
So what notify does
is it indicates
to any other thread
that is waiting
on a particular variable
that that thread can run.
So the HTML thread
will notify free,
which will tell the disk
thread that it can now
begin running if it had been
waiting on the variable free.
OK, so this emulates the
behavior of the while loop
that we had before except that
the thread scheduler, rather
than sitting in an
infinite while loop simply
doesn't schedule the HTML
thread or the disk thread
while it's waiting in one
of these wait statements.
OK, so what we're going
to talk about for the rest
of the lecture today
is related to this,
and I think you will see why
as we get through the talk.
The topic for today
is performance.
So performance, what we've
looked at so far in this class
are these various ways of
structuring complex programs,
how to break them up
into several modules,
the client/server
paradigm, how threads work,
how a thread scheduler works,
all of these sort of big topics
about how you design a system.
But we haven't said anything
about how you take a system
design and in an ordered,
regular, systematic way, think
about making that
system run efficiently.
So that's what we're going
to try and get at today.
We're going to look
at a set of techniques
that we can use to make a
computer system more efficient.
And so, these techniques,
there are really
three techniques that we're
going to look at today.
The first one is a technique
called concurrency.
And concurrency is really
about allowing the system
to perform multiple
operations simultaneously.
So, for example, in
our sample Web server,
it may be the case that
we have this disc that we
can sort of read pages
from at the same time
that, for example, the
CPU generates some Web
pages that it's going
to output to the client.
OK, so that's what
concurrency is about.
We are also going to look at
a technique called caching,
which you guys should
have all seen before.
Caching is really
just about saving off
some previous work, some
previous computation
that we've already done,
or our previous disk page
that we've already read in.
We want to save it off so
that we can reuse it again
at a later time.
And then finally,
we are going to look
at something called scheduling.
So scheduling is about when
we have multiple requests
to process, we might
be able to order
those requests in a certain
way or group the requests
together in a certain
way so that we can
make the system more efficient.
So it's really about sort of
choosing the order in which we
do things in order to make the
system run more efficiently.
And throughout the
course of this,
I'm going to use this
example of this Web server
that we've been talking
about to sort of motivate
each of the applications,
or each of these performance
techniques that we're
going to talk about.
So in order to get
to the point where
we can understand how these
performance techniques work,
we need to talk a
little bit about what
we mean by performance.
How do we measure the
performance of the system,
and how do we understand where
the bottlenecks in performance
in a system might be?
So one thing we might want to,
the first thing we need to do
is to define a set of
performance metrics.
These are just a set of
terms and definitions
that we can use so
that we can talk
about what the performance
of the system is.
So the first metric we
might be interested in
is the capacity of the system.
And capacity is
simply some measure
of the amount of
resource in a system.
So this sounds kind of abstract,
but what we mean by a resource
is some sort of thing
that we can compete with.
It's a disk, or a
CPU, or a network,
so we might, for example, talk
about the capacity of a disk
might be the size in gigabytes
or the capacity of a processor
might be the number
of instructions
it can execute per second.
OK, so once we have
capacity, now we
can start talking about
how much of the system
we are actually using.
So we talk about
the utilization.
So utilization is simply
the percentage of capacity
we're using.
So we might have used up
80% of the disk blocks
on our computer.
So now there are two sort of
properties, or two metrics that
are very commonly used
in computer systems
in order to classify or sort of
talk about what the performance
of the system is.
So, the first metric is latency.
So, latency is simply the time
for a request to complete.
The REQ is request,
OK, and we can also
talk about sort of
the inverse of this,
what at first will seem
like the inverse of this,
which is throughput.
That's simply the number
of requests per second
that we can process.
So when you think about
latency and throughput,
when you first see
this definition,
it's tempting to think
that simply throughput is
the inverse of latency, right?
If it takes 10 ms for
a request to complete,
well, then I must
be able to complete
100 requests per second, right?
And, that's true
in the simple case
where in the very
simple example where
I have a single module, for
example, that can process one
request at a time, so a
single computational resource,
for example, that can only
do one thing at a time,
if this thing has some
infinite set of inputs in it,
it takes 10 ms to
process each input,
we'll see, say, 100 results
per second coming out, OK?
So if something
takes 10 ms to do,
you can be 100 of
them per second.
So we could say the
throughput of this system
is 100 per second, and
the latency is 10 ms.
What we're going to see
throughout this talk is
that in fact a strict
relationship between latency
and throughput
doesn't hold I mean,
you guys have
probably already seen
the notion of pipelining
before in 6.004,
and you understand
that pipelining
is a way in which we can improve
the throughput of the system
without necessarily
changing the latency.
And we'll talk about that more
carefully as this talk goes on.
OK, so given these metrics,
now what we need to do
is think a little bit about, OK,
so suppose I have some system,
and suppose I have some sort
of set of goals for that system
like I want the system
to be able to process
a certain number of
requests per second,
or I want the latency of this
system to be under some amount.
So then the question is, so you
are given this computer system
and you sit down and
you want to measure it.
And so you're going
to measure the system.
And what do you expect to find?
So, in the design
of computer systems,
it turns out that there is some
sort of well-known performance
pitfalls, or so-called
performance bottlenecks.
And the goal of sort of
doing performance analysis
of a system is to
look at the system
and figure out where
the bottlenecks are.
So, this typically in the
design of the big computer
system, what we're
worried about is
which of the little individual
modules within the system
is most responsible for
slowing down my computer.
And what should
I do in order to,
sort of, and then once you've
identified that module, picking
about how to make a particular
module that slow run faster.
So that's really what finding
performance bottlenecks
is about.
And there's a classic bottleneck
that occurs in computer systems
that you guys all
need to know about.
It's this so-called
I/O bottleneck.
OK, so what the
I/O bottleneck says
it's really fairly
straightforward.
If you think about
a computer system,
it has a hierarchy of
memory devices in it, OK?
And these memory devices
start, or storage devices.
So these storage devices
first start with the CPU.
So the CPU has some
set of registers on it,
a small number of them,
say for example, 32.
And you can access those
registers very, very fast,
say once per instruction, once
per cycle on the computer.
So, for example, if your
CPU is one gigahertz,
you may be able to access
one of these registers in 1
nanosecond.
OK, and so typically at the
tallest level, of this pyramid,
we have a small storage
that is fast, OK?
As we go down this
pyramid adding new layers,
and looking at this
storage hierarchy,
we're going to see that
things get bigger and slower.
So, just below the CPU, we may
have some processor cache, OK,
and this might be,
for example, 512 kB.
And it might take 20 ns
to access a single, say,
block of this memory.
And then we're going to have
the RAM, the main memory
of the device, which on a
modern machine might be 1 GB.
And it might take
100 ns to access.
And then below that, you take
a big step down or big step up
in size and big step
down and performance.
You typically have a disk.
So a disk might be as
big as 100 GB, right?
But, performance is very slow.
So it's a mechanical
thing that has to spin,
and it only spins so fast.
So a typical access time
for a block of the disk
might be as high as
10 ms or even higher.
And then sometimes
people will talk
in this hierarchy the network
is actually a level below that.
So if something isn't available
on the local disk, for example,
on our Web server,
we might actually
have to go out into the
network and fetch it.
And if this network
is the Internet,
right, the Internet has
a huge amount of data.
I mean, who knows
how much it is.
It's certainly
orders of terabytes.
And it could take a long time
to get a page of the Internet.
So it might take 100 ms
to reach some remote site
on the Internet.
All right, so the point
about this I/O bottleneck
is that this is going to
be a very common, sort
of the disparity
in the performance
of these different
levels of the system
is going to be a very
common source of performance
problems in our computers.
So in particular, if you look
at the access time, here's 1 ns.
The access time
down here is 100 ms.
This is a ten to the
eighth difference, right,
which is equal to
100 million times
difference in the performance
of the fastest to the slowest
thing here.
So, if the CPU has
to wait for something
to come over the network, you're
waiting for a very long time
in terms of the amount of time
the CPU takes to, say, read
a single word of memory.
So when we look at the
performance of a computer
system, we're going
to see that often
this sort of I/O bottleneck is
the problem with that system.
So if we look, for
example, at our Web server,
with its three stages, where
this stage is the one that
goes to disk, this is the HTML
stage, which maybe can just
be computed in memory.
And this is the network stage.
We might be talking about 10
ms latency for the disk stage.
We might be talking about
just 1 ms for the HTML page,
because all it has to do is
do some computation in memory.
And we might be talking about
100 ms for the network stage
to run because it has
to send some data out
to some remote site.
So if you, in order to
process a single request,
have to go through each of
these steps in sequence,
then the total
performance of the system,
the time to process a single
request is going to be,
say for example, 111 ms, the
sum of these three things, OK?
And so if you look at the
system and you say, OK,
what's the performance
bottleneck in this system?
So the performance
bottleneck, right,
is clearly this network stage
because it takes the longest
to run.
And so if we want to answer a
question about where we should
be optimizing the
system, one place
we might think to optimize
is within this network stage.
And we'll see later an
example of a simple kind
of optimization
that we can apply
based on this notion
of concurrency
to improve the performance
of the networking stage.
So as I just said, the
notion of concurrency
is going to be the
way that we are really
going to get at sort of
eliminating these I/O
bottlenecks.
So -- And the idea is going
to be that we want to overlap
the use of some other resource
during the time that we are
waiting for one of these
slow I/O devices to complete.
And, we are going to look
at two types of concurrency.
We're going to look at
concurrency between modules --
-- and within a module, OK?
So we may have modules that
are composed, for example,
our networking module
may be composed
of multiple threads,
each of which
can be accessing the network.
So that's an example of
concurrency within a module.
And, we're going
to look at the case
of between module concurrency
where, for example, the HTML
module can be processing and
be generating an HTML page,
while the disk module is reading
a request for another client
at the same time.
OK, and so the idea
behind concurrency
is really going to be
that by using concurrency,
we can hide the latency of
one of these slow I/O stages.
OK, so the first
kind of concurrency
we're going to talk about is
concurrency between modules.
And the primary technique we use
for doing this is pipelining.
So the idea with
pipelining is as follows.
Suppose we have our
Web server again.
And this time let's
draw it as I drew it
at first with queues between
each of the modules, OK?
So, we have our Web server
which has our three stages.
And suppose that
what we are doing
is we have some set
of requests, sort
of an infinite queue of requests
that is sort of queued up
at the disk thread,
and the disk thread
is producing these things.
And we're sending them through.
Well, we want to look at
how many pages come out
here per second, and what
the latency of each page is.
So, if we have some
list of requests,
suppose these requests are
numbered R1 through Rn, OK?
So what's going to happen
is that the first request is
going to start being processed
by the disk server, right?
So, it's going to
start processing R1.
Now, in a pipelining system,
what we're going to want to do
is to have each one of these
threads sort of working
on a different request, each
one of these modules working
on a different request
at each point in time.
And because the disk is
an independent resource
from the CPU, is an independent
resource from the network,
this is going to be OK.
These three modules
aren't actually
going to contend with
each other too much.
So what's going to happen
is this guy's going
to start processing R1, right?
And then after 10 ms, he's
going to pass R1 up to here,
and start working on R2, OK?
And now, 1 ms after
that, this guy
is going to finish R1
and send it to here.
And then, 9 ms after that,
R2 is going to come up here.
And this guy can
start processing R3.
OK, so does everybody
sort of see where
those numbers are coming from?
OK.
[LAUGHTER] Good.
So now, what we're going to do
is if we look at time starting
with this equal to time zero, in
terms of the requests that come
in and out of this
last network thread,
we can sort of get
a sense of how fast
this thing is processing.
So the first R1 enters into
this system after 11 ms, right?
It takes 10 ms to get
through here and 1 ms
to get through here.
And, it starts processing
R1 at this time.
So, I'm going to write
plus R1 to suggest that we
start processing it here.
The next time that this
module can do anything
is 100 ms after it first
started processing,
the next time this module does
anything is 100 ms after it
started processing R1.
So, at time 111 ms,
it can output R1,
or it's done processing R1.
And then, of course, by
that time, R2 and R3,
some set of requests
have already queued up
in this queue waiting for it.
So it can immediately begin
processing R2 at this time, OK?
So then, clearly what's going
to happen is after 211 ms,
it's going to
output R2, and it's
going to begin
processing R3, OK?
So, there should be a plus
there and a plus there.
So, and similarly,
at 311 we're going
to move on to the next one.
So, if you look
now at the system,
we've done something
pretty interesting,
which is that it
still took us, sort
of the time for this request to
travel through this whole thing
was 110 ms.
But if you look at the
enter - arrival time
between each of these
successive outputs of R1,
they are only 100 ms, right?
So we are only
waiting as long as it
takes R1 to process
a result in order
to produce these results,
in order to produce answers.
So by pipelining the
system in this way
and having the Web server
thread and the disk thread
do their processing
on later requests
while R1 is processing
its request,
we can increase the
throughput of the system.
So in this case, we get
an arrival every 100 ms.
So the throughput is now equal
to one result every 100 ms,
or ten results per second, OK?
So, even though the
latency is still 111 ms,
the throughput is no
longer one over the latency
because we have separated them
in this way by pipelining them.
OK, so that was good.
That was nice.
We improve the performance
of the system a little bit.
But we didn't really
improve it very much, right?
We increased the throughput
of this thing a little bit.
But we haven't really addressed
what we identified earlier as
being a bottleneck, which the
fact that this R1 stage is
taking 100 ms to process.
And in general, when we have
a pipeline system like this,
we can say that the
throughput of the system
is bottlenecked by the
slowest stage of the system.
So anytime you have a pipeline,
the throughput of the system
is going to be the throughput
of the slowest stage.
So in this case, the throughput
is 10 results per second.
And that's the throughput
of the whole system.
So if we want to improve
the throughput anymore
than this, what we're
going to have to do
is to somehow improve the
performance of this module
here.
And the way that
we're going to do that
is also by exploiting
concurrency.
This is going to be this
within a module concurrency.
So if you think about
how a Web server works,
or how a network
works, typically
when we are sending these
requests to a client,
it's not that we are using up
all of the available bandwidth
of the network when we
are sending these requests
to a client, right?
You may be able to send
100 MB per second out
over your network.
Or if you're connected
to a machine here,
you may be able to send 10 MB
a second across the country
to some other university.
The issue is that it takes
a relatively long time
for that request to
propagate, especially
when that request is propagating
out over the Internet.
The latency can be quite high.
But you may not be
using all the bandwidth
when you are, say, for
example, sending an HTML page.
So in particular it is the case
that multiple applications,
multiple threads, can be
simultaneously sending data out
over the network.
And if that doesn't make
sense to you right now,
we're going to spend the whole
next four lectures talking
about network performance.
And it should make
sense for you.
So just take my
word for it that one
of the properties
of the network is
so that the latency of the
network may be relatively high.
But in this case
we are not actually
going to be using all
the bandwidth that's
available to us.
So that suggests that
there is an idle resource.
It means that we sort
of have some network
bandwidth that we could be
using that we are not using.
So we'd like to take
advantage of that
in the design of our system.
So we can do this in a
relatively simple way, which
is simply to say, let's,
within our networking module,
rather than only having one
thread sending out requests
at one time, let's
have multiple threads.
Let's, for example have,
say we have 10 threads.
So we have thread one,
thread two, thread ten, OK?
And we're going to
allow these all to be
using the network at once.
And they are all
going to be talking
to the same queue that's
connected to the same HTML
module that's connected
to the same disk module.
And there's a queue
between these as well.
OK, so now when we think
about the performance of this,
now let's see what happens
when we start running requests
through this pipeline.
And let's see how frequently
we get requests coming out
of the other end.
We draw our timeline again.
You can see that R1 is
going to come in here,
and then after 10 ms it's
going to move to here.
And then after 11 ms
it'll arrive here.
We'll start processing
request one.
Now the second request,
R2, is going to be here.
And, we're going to have 9 ms
of processing left to do on it.
After R1, it gets sent
on to the next thread.
So, R2 is going to
be in here for 9 ms.
It will be in here for 1 ms.
So, 10 ms after R1 arrives here,
R2 is going to arrive here.
So, what we have
is we have 11 ms.
We have R1.
Now, 10 ms later, we have R2.
OK, so now you can
see that suddenly
this module, this system is able
to process multiple requests,
so it has multiple requests that
processing at the same time.
And so 10 ms after that, R3 is
going to start being processed,
and then, so what that means
is that after some passage
of time, we're going
to have R10 in here.
And, that's going to go
in after 101 ms, right?
So, we're going to get R10.
OK, and now we are ready
to start processing.
Now we've sort of pushed
all these through.
And now, suppose we
start processing R11.
OK, so R11 is going to
flow through this pipeline.
And then, it's at
time 111, R11 is going
to be ready to be processed.
But notice that at
time 111, we are
finished processing R1, right?
So, at this time, we can
add R11 to the system,
and we can output R1.
OK, so now every
10 ms after this,
another result is
going to arrive,
and we're going to be able
to output the next one.
OK, and this is just
going to continue.
So now, you see
what we've managed
to do is we've made this
system so that every 10
ms after this sort of
startup time of 111 ms,
after every 10 ms, we are
producing a result, right?
So we are going to get,
actually, 100 per second.
This is going to be the
throughput of this system now.
OK, so that was kind of neat.
How did we do that?
What have we done here?
Well, effectively
what we've done
is we've made it so
that this module here
can process sort of 10
times as many requests
as it could before.
So this module itself now
has 10 times the throughput
that it had before.
And we said before that the
bottleneck in the system
is, the throughput of the
system is the throughput
of the slowest stage.
So what we've managed to do
is decrease the throughput
of the slowest stage.
And so now the system is
running 10 times as fast.
Notice now that the disk
thread and the network threads
both take 10 ms, sort of the
throughput of each of them
is 100 per second.
And so, now we have sort of two
stages that have been equalized
in their throughput.
And so if we wanted
to further increase
the performance
of the system, we
would have to increase
the performance
of both of these stages,
not just one of them.
OK, so that was a
nice result, right?
It seems like we've
done something sort of,
we've shown that we can use
this notion of concurrency
to increase the
performance of a system.
But, we've introduced a
little bit of a problem.
In particular, the problem
we've introduced is as follows.
So, remember, we said we
had this set of threads,
one through, say for example,
ten, that our processing,
they're all sharing
this queue data
structure that is connected
up to our HTML thread.
So, the problem with this
is that what we've done
is to introduce what's called
a race condition on this queue.
And I'll show you
what I mean by that.
So if we look at
our code snippet
up here, for example for what's
happening in our HTML thread,
we see that what it does
is it calls dequeue, right?
So the problem
that we can have is
that we may have multiple
of these modules that
are simultaneously
executing at the same time.
And they may simultaneously
both call dequeue, right?
So depending on how
dequeue is implemented,
we can get some weird results.
So, let me give
you a sort of very
simple possible
implementation of dequeue.
Suppose that what
dequeue does is it reads,
so, given this queue here, let's
say the queue is managed by,
there's two variables that
keep track of the current state
of this queue.
There is a variable
called first,
which points to the
head of the queue,
and there's a variable
called last, which --
first points to the first
used element in this queue,
and last points to
the last used element.
So, the elements that are in
use in the queue at any one time
are between first and last, OK?
And, what's going to
happen is when we dequeue,
we're going to sort of
move first over one, right?
So, when we dequeue something,
we'll free up this cell.
And when we enqueue,
we'll move last down one.
And then, when last
reaches the end,
we are going to wrap it around.
So this is a fairly standard
implementation of a queue.
It's called the circular buffer.
And if first is equal
to last, then we
know that the queue is full.
So that's the condition
that we can check.
So we are not going to
go into too many details
about how this thing is
actually implemented.
But let's look at a very
simple example of how dequeue
might work.
So remember we have these
two shared variables first
and last that are
shared between these,
say, all these threads that
are accessing this thing.
And what dequeue might do is to
say it's going to read a block,
read a page from this
queue, so read the next HTML
page to output, and
it's going to read that
into a local
variable called page.
Let's call this
queue buf, B-U-F,
I mean we'll use a array
notation for accessing it.
So it's going to read
buf sub first, OK,
and then it's going
to increment first.
First gets first plus one, and
then it's going to return page.
OK, that seems like a
straightforward implementation
of dequeue.
And so we have one
thread that's doing this.
Now, suppose we have
another thread that's
doing exactly the same
thing at the same time.
So it runs exactly
the same code.
And remember that these
two threads are sharing
the variables buf and first.
OK, so if you think about this
if you think about these two
things running two
threads at the same time,
there is sort of an interesting
problem that can arise.
So one thing that might happen
when we are running these two
things at the same time is
that the thread scheduler might
first start running thread one.
And it might run the first
instruction of thread one.
And then it might run
the second instruction.
this return thing.
And then it might
come over here,
and it might start running T2.
So, it might, then, stop
running T1 and start running T2,
and execute its
three instructions.
So if the thread scheduler does
this, there's nothing wrong.
It's not a problem, right?
The thread scheduler,
each of these things
read its value from the
queue and incremented it.
T1 read one thing
from the queue,
and then T2 read the next
thing from the queue.
So clearly some of the time
this is going to work fine.
So let's make a list
of possible outcomes.
Sometimes we'll be OK.
The first possible
outcome was OK.
But let's look at a
different situation.
Suppose what happens is that
the first thing the thread
scheduler does is schedule T1.
And T1 executes this
first instruction,
and then just after that
the thread scheduler
decides to pre-empt T1, and
allow T2 to start running.
So it in particular
allows T2 to execute
this dequeue
instruction to its end,
and then it comes over
here and it runs T1.
OK, so what's the problem now?
Yeah?
Right, OK, so they've both
read in the same page variable.
So now both of these threads
have dequeued the same page.
So the value first, for
T1, it was pointing here.
And then we switched.
And it was still
pointing here, right?
And now, so both of these
guys have read the same page.
And now they are both at some
point going to increment first.
So you're going to
increment it once.
Then you're going to
increment it again.
So this second element here
in the queue has been skipped.
OK, so this is a problem.
We don't want this to happen.
Because the system is not
outputting all the pages
that it was supposed to output.
So what can we do to fix this?
So the way that we fixed this
is by introducing something
we call isolation primitives.
And the basic idea
is that we want
to introduce an operation
that will make it
so that any time that
the page variable gets
read out of the queue, that
we also at the same time
increment first without any
other sort of threads' accesses
to this queue being
interleaved with our accesses
to this queue, or our
dequeues from the queue.
So in sort of technical
terms, what we say is
we want these two things,
the reading of page
and the incrementing of
first to be so-called atomic.
OK, and the way that we're going
to make these things atomic
is by isolating them
from each other, that
by isolating these two
threads from each other
when they are executing the
enqueue and dequeue things.
So, these two terms we're
going to come back to
in a few months in the class
towards the end of the class.
But all you need
to understand here
is that there is
this race condition,
and we want some
way to prevent it.
And the way that
we're going to prevent
it is by using these isolation
routines also sometimes
called locks.
So in this case, the
isolation schemes
are going to be called locks.
So the idea is that a lock
is simply a variable, which
can be in one of two states.
It can either be set or unset.
And we have two operations
that we can apply on a lock.
We can acquire it,
and we can release it.
OK, and acquire and release
have the following behavior.
What acquire says is check
the state of the lock,
and if the lock is unset,
then change the state to set.
But if the lock
is set, then wait
until the lock becomes unset.
What a release says is
it simply says change
the state of the lock from unset
to set, or from set to unset,
excuse me.
So let's see how we can use
these two routines in our code.
So let's go back to our
example of enqueue and dequeue.
Let's introduce a lock variable.
We'll call it TL
for thread lock.
And, what we're going to do
is simply around these two
operations to access the
queue, to modify this page
and first, to read the
page and modify first,
we're going to put in an
acquire and a release.
OK so we have ACQ
on this thread lock,
and we have release
on this thread lock.
OK, so let's look,
so this seems fine.
It looks like we've done this.
But it's sort of positing
the existence of this acquire
procedure that just sort
of does the right thing.
If you think about
this for a minute,
it seems like we can have
the same race condition
problem in the acquire module
as well, right, or the acquire
function as well.
With two guys both try
and acquire the lock
at the same time?
How are we going to
avoid this problem?
And there's a
couple of ways that
are sort of well
understood for avoiding
this problem in
practice, and they're
talked about in the book.
I'm just going to introduce
the simplest of them
now, which is that we're going
to add a special instruction
to the microprocessor
that allows us to do this,
acquire efficiently.
It turns out that most
modern microprocessors
have an equivalent instruction.
So we're going to
call this instruction
RSL for read-set- lock.
OK, so the idea with
RSL is as follows.
We can basically,
the implementation
of the acquire module is
going to be like this.
What it's going to
do, remember we want
to wait until we want to loop.
We don't have the lock.
If we don't have
the lock, we want
to loop until
we've had the lock.
So the implementation
require may look as follows.
We'll have a local
variable called held.
We'll initially set it
to false in a while loop
while we don't hold the lock.
We're going to use
this RSL instruction.
So, what this says is
held equals RSL of TL, OK?
So, what the RSL
instruction does
is it looks at the state of the
lock, and if the lock is unset,
then it sets it.
And if the lock is set, then
it sets it and it returns true.
And if the lock is set,
then it returns false.
So it has the property
that it can both read
and set the lock within a
single instruction, right?
And we're going to use this read
and set lock sort of primitive,
this basic thing,
as a way to build up
this sort of more complicated
acquire function, which
we can then use to
build up these locks.
OK, so anytime you're designing
a multithreaded system
in this way, or a system
with lots of concurrency,
you should be worrying
about whether you
have race conditions.
And if you have
race conditions, you
need to think about how to
use locks in order to prevent
those race conditions.
Alright, so there are a
couple of other topics related
to performance that
appear in the text.
And one of those
topics is caching.
And I just want to spend one
very brief minute on caching.
So you guys have already
seen catching presumably
in the context of 6.004
with processor caches.
And what we would
want to do, so you
might want to sit
down and think through
as an example of how
you would use a cache
to improve the performance
of our Web server.
So one thing that
you might do in order
to improve the performnence
of the Web server
is to put a cace
in the disk thread
that you use instead of going to
disk in order to sort of reduce
the latency of a disk access.
And I'll at the beginning
of class next time
take you through a
very simple example
of how we can actually use
the disk thread in order
to do that.
But you guys should think about
this a little bit on your own.
So barring that
little digression
that we'll have next
time, this takes us
to the end of our discussion
of sort of modularity,
abstraction, and performance.
And what we're going
to start talking
about next time is
networking, and how networks
But I want you guys
to make sure you
keep in mind all these
topics that we've
talked about because
these are going
to be the sort of
fundamental tools
that we are going to
use throughout the class
in the design of
computer systems.
So because we've
finished this module,
it doesn't mean that
it's sort of OK to stop
thinking about this stuff.
You need to keep all of this
in mind at the same time.
So we'll see you
all on Wednesday.